hello everyone thank you for coming the
uh the topic of discussion today in this
panel of course is uh the phenomena of
Christian persecution under various
Islamic lands particularly in the Middle
East and the panel with me here today
who I'll introduce later are all going
to discuss various hot spots where this
is happening I myself will discuss the
situation with the Coptic Christians of
Egypt but first I'd like to make some
quick introductory remarks to try to put
the whole thing into context um I I like
to like bring it back to the Arab Spring
even though what we're going to discuss
has been happening for a lot longer the
Arab Spring ever since it's it's come
about has uh become even though the
media originally portrayed it as some
sort of democratic movement and to be
sure there was elements of that who
apparently Got Hijacked but it's
becoming more of an Islamic spring or as
others would call it an Islamic winter
depending on who you who you talk to and
during this time of the Arab Spring I
like to talk let's say starting January
11 the plight of Christian minorities in
the various Middle Eastern countries and
really not even just Middle Eastern
countries but anywhere Islamic countries
as far east as Pakistan and uh into
subsaharan Africa especially Nigeria but
other countries the same sorts of
patterns have been coming about of
persecution and uh it's interesting for
me to always try to show that there's a
lot of continuity involved in this and
it's not just an aberration it is an
aberration in the modern era because in
the last 100 50 years or even more as a
lot of Christians under Islam know it
was it was considered the golden age for
Christians Christian minorities because
uh there was a lot more secularism among
Muslims because it was also the time of
colonialism and there were a lot more
freedoms for example the gizia or the
tax that Christians had to pay was uh
abolished in the 19th century but so now
we are returning sort of to a more
historical Islam especially the early
Islam and I like to start by discussing
uh you're probably or you may not be
familiar with the concept of theud which
really means the word themi which is a
legal term for non-muslims who live
under Islam and thei there are lots of
rules for how they should be governed
and it really begins uh According to
Islamic scholars and Islamic tradition
with What's called the conditions of
Omar or commonly known as The Pact of
Omar and this would be the second khif
who made that he made that pact with um
the conquered Christians of Jerusalem
other people say it was in Syria other
people say it wasn't even Omar it was a
later addition these are scholarly
points but suffice to say According to
Islamic understanding The Pact of Omar
is a pivotal text that dimude or the
laws for thei were built upon and the
reason I bring it up is because even
though this pact of Omar is believed to
have been ratified in the 7th century
and it was added on to later by
different kifs and of course the jurists
it makes mention of various items that
are still relevant and we are seeing
come back today I'll just discuss two
and I will discuss those two in the
context of Egypt because Egypt to me is
sort of the Paradigm of vitude and the
reason I say that is because Egypt from
a historical point of view was one of
those was a primary Christian country
most people aren't aware that it was
really a Christian Center especially
Alexandria actually VI with Rome as far
as ecclesiastical Authority but when the
Islamic conquest happened in 7th century
and slowly of course Christians became
minorities but there's still a large
number and depending on who you ask
there's up to 15 million Christians in
Egypt and so the reason it becomes a
paradigm of nitude is because there's so
many Christians that you see the sort of
laws coming up because in other
countries where there aren't that many
you won't see much of this because
they're not there anyway so the two
points I'd like to discuss or the
paradigms the first one is um
churches in when you look at The Pact of
Omar and the subsequent thei status laws
that were built upon it there's a great
Focus put on churches and uh the
basically got distilled down to churches
could not be built new ones and old ones
should be left to crumble away and
they're not to be renovated now this of
course with the vicissitudes of History
sometimes happened in a very dramatic
way with lots of Destruction and other
times it was more tolerant and
especially as I was mentioning during
the colonial era or the golden age but
now it's coming back and I'll just give
you a quick list to give you an idea of
how this happens in the PA of Omar it
specifically States not only can they
not be built or renovated but they
should should not have visible crosses
there should not be bells or loud
singing because that's offensive to
Islam and so um one of the churches a
few months ago called meib which is in
near edu in Aswan was a classic case of
this it was it was built 100 years ago
and it was so dilapitated that they
tried to fix it the cops and they
actually got a permit for it local
Muslims were not happy with this and
they started saying things like we don't
want to see a church on it the Dome
needs to be taken down make a long story
short after Friday prayers as often is
the time when Muslim mobs will go and
attack they came and destroyed that
church and in fact that was the one
church that caused uh you may know the
maspiro massacre because after that
church was uh destroyed cops in Mass
protested because this was not the first
church of course a few months earlier
there was a church in Soul and it was an
ancient church and um Muslims went up
with sledgehammers destroyed it
completely raised it to the ground spent
10 hours doing that police forces didn't
do anything and um marab as or that
church in edu was done again in very
classical Doctrine because they had they
you're not supposed to renovate it
you're not supposed to put a cross
you're not supposed to have bells and
Muslims took the law in their own hands
in that region as for the Church of soul
that also has precedent it was it was in
the the the pre or the pretext for why
it was attacked was because in the
region a Coptic Christian man was
accused of having a relationship with a
Muslim woman and that too is part of the
themma law law which means Christians
can never have Christian men cannot uh
marry Muslim women and so it was part of
a collective punishment because of that
fact Muslims Rose destroyed that church
then there was the imaba churches or the
imaba riots a few months before that and
in this case two or three churches were
attacked and burned and again there was
some pretext that wasn't even real the
pretext basically was that apparently
some Coptic girl excuse me wanted to
convert to Islam and cops were
preventing her so Muslims right Ed
destroyed three churches and some
Christians were killed then of course
there's the New Year's attack you may
remember that that's the one that
actually made it to the mainstream media
where um during midnight mass uh the
Church of two Saints was attacked 23
people killed all of this happened right
around the time of the Arab Spring by
the way and um but it's also been
happening before that but it's coming
back now with a passion the other aspect
that's very important is that while we
can say under Mubarak churches were
attacked because they have been since
the probably 1970s hundreds have been
attacked in Egypt but there's a new
theme that also traces back to the
themma laws and The Pact of Omar which
is this new idea of blasphemy codes in
Egypt now whereas under mubarak's Reign
there were very very minimal rare cases
of Christians being accused of blasphemy
which is to say insulting or offending
Muhammad today there is approximately 17
cases there's eight there were 18 cases
and this is all had happened ever since
Mubarak was ousted and basically under
Muslim Brotherhood opes of the 18 cases
17 of them are Christians one was a
Muslim and he was exonerated the other
17 are all either in jail or pending uh
or or or waiting one one for instance
was a pregnant woman who who basically
said something and it was interpreted a
pregnant woman teacher who teaching said
Prophet Muhammad but she didn't finish
it up by saying in Arabic sallallahu
alaih wasallam which is basically peace
and blessings upon him this was
construed as blasphemy and because she's
pregnant she was left alone until she
delivers the baby and then she she may
well be tried another case was a teacher
who on his Facebook account put
something that was deemed insulting to
Muhammad he got six years another case
17-year-old student on his Facebook he
only has 130 friends 130 friends he put
something it was discovered he got three
years in jail and there's a lot more um
there's a lot more cases of this uh and
they're not unlike you may have heard in
Pakistan the Rima case the young
Pakistani girl that was accused of
tearing up a Quran same identical thing
happened a couple of weeks ago two
little Coptic boys I think nine and 10
were accused of tearing up a Quran
turned out that they're illiterate they
don't even know what the book was it was
in a garbage and it was already torn up
and there were riots and people wanted
them
arrested and or worst and it's important
to keep in mind that that whereas the
churches they're getting worse the
attacks on churches and that this has a
lot of continuity with Islamic history
and tradition and Doctrine this
blasphemy thing is very much a
reflection of the new rule in Egypt
which is basically with the islamization
of Egypt and with the rise and
prominence of the copies and of course
the Muslim Brotherhood blasphemy like I
said under Mubarak was not a prominent
issue you had a rare case every few
years now in a few months we've already
got 17 so the issue is obviously there
it's a real thing of course the problem
is the mainstream is not aware of it
because these topics rarely make it into
the mainstream and when they do they're
sort of watered down I remember for
instance the New Year's Eve church
bombing where 23 people were killed um
you know it's 23 Church middle of the
night worshiping it was bombed 23 people
dead and the New York Times headline was
basically Muslims and Christians Riot
and
Clash sectarian Strife so you read it
and you get the impression that
basically well it's it's an equal kind
of conflict and that's not the case at
all um and of course we're going to hear
now from other people about different
regions who I'll be introducing shortly
and I think it's important to keep in
mind as you listen to them that we're
I'm talking about Egypt they're going to
talk about other countries Iraq Iran and
elsewhere and it's interesting to note
the parallels the things that you will
see so what's happening in Iraq and Iran
will be what's happening in Egypt and
it's even worse than that you can leave
the Arab world go to Nigeria churches
are probably daily attacked there by boo
Haram or Western education as is saying
the militant Islamic Jihadi group go far
into Pakistan same exact thing so these
patterns are not aberration they're not
cultural issues they have a long
tradition and they trace back to
something else and I think that's the
big picture at this point I'd like to
introduce our first panelist uh Juliana
Taurasi uh she's an Assyrian Christian
born in Iran and she fled Iran and and
received um Asylum eventually and she's
the founder of the Iraqi Christian
relief Council who helps try to empower
various Christian minorities in Iraq and
elsewhere